and travel isn't any easier for drivers
in the Midwest mr. Chris mentioned the
storm caused whiteout conditions from
Nebraska to Chicago forcing some major
highways to shut down Dean Reynolds is
in Oak Park Illinois just west of
Chicago team good morning good morning
with the snow here falling at about two
inches an hour it would be easy to pile
up more than a foot by the end of the
day the beginning of the day is
featuring a very difficult commute while
elsewhere in the Midwest just getting
home from the holiday was proving to be
a real challenge an autumn blizzard
blanketed the Midwest Sunday blustery
winds and heavy snow swallowed parts of
the i-80 and i-70 corridor reducing
visibility to zero and making driving
nearly impossible
we are literally driving and cannot see
anything
accidents littered the roadways while
jackknifed tractor-trailer xand disabled
cars blocked highways and interstates
you better have an extra dose of
patience to get through all this between
people just not making good choices and
not being patient with not only the road
but other drivers in trouble every time
in Kansas City a tractor-trailer nearly
pitched off an overpass after sliding
into the guardrail this is probably one
of the worst I've ever seen in Kansas
you can't see in front of you you cannot
see where the roadway is at in Kansas
the governor issued a state of emergency
interstate 70 which spans much of the
state was shut down we were supposed to
be on afternoon flight we preemptively
changed it to avoid the snow and then we
were stuck in traffic so she still
missed the flight at O'Hare Airport in
Chicago more than 800 flights were
canceled slowing one of the busiest
airports in the country on one of the
busiest travel days Chicago Mayor Rahm
Emanuel it's all hands on deck effort
for the city we have been here before
this is the first snow of this season
and as of this magnitude it has a lot of
unpredictability a winter storm warning
is now in effect for the Chicago metro
area and more than a hundred and seventy
thousand customers are without power
meanwhile the Coast Guard is warning
people to stay away from the shoreline
of Lake Michigan where waves could reach
a height of 18 feet John Wow Thank You
Dean 18 feet